لكن مشاهدينا بعيدا عن الميدان الولايات
المتحده تحاول دفع حلفائها لتخفيف حده
الخطاب المعادي لروسيا وبحسب مصادر تحدثت
لصحيفه
قالت ان الرئيس جو بايدن ضغط خلال زيارته
مؤخرا الى بولندا ضغط على قاده دول
البلطيق لتليين مواقفهم تجاه روسيا وهي
الضغوط التي تسببت بشكوك في دول البلطيق
حول ما اذا كانت واشنطن تعتبر هزيمه روسيا
في الصراع في اوكرانيا هدفا واقعيا
بالتزامن اعرب حلفاء ليكيا في اوروبا
الشرقيه عن مخاوفهم بسبب التزايد ظهور
الافكار التي تفيد بانه يجب على اوكرانيا
ان تستعد للمفاوضات مع روسيا في مرحله ما
لكن على الجانب العسكري اعلن وزير الدفاع
الامريكي استون ان القوات الامريكيه
ستحافظ على وجودها في دول البلطيق بعد ان
تظل ملتزمه بحريه وسياده هذه الدول وردعي
اي تهديد للامن المشترك واستنقال في مؤتمر
صحفي مشترك مع وزير الدفاع الاستوني
في العاصمه لين انني يزيد من امكاناته في
مجال الردع ويزيد من مستوى الدفاع في
الجزء الشرقي من الحلف كما تعزز الولايات
المتحده وجودها على الجانب الشرقي من
الحلف وستحافظ على وجودها المستقر في دول
البلطيق
ليله
يعزز الردع والدفاع في الجناح الشرقي كما
تعمل الولايات المتحده على تعزيز وجودها
في دول البلطيق وسوف نحافظ على وجود دوري
دائم في هذه الدول
نشرت مقالا تحليليا تناولت فيه اخطار اي
تفاوض محتمل بين روسيا واوكرانيا في
المستقبل القريب او حتى البعيد الصحيفه
اعتبرت ان محادثات السلام مع روسيا لا
طائله منها ما لم يتخلى بوتين عن طموحه
لدفع الناتو بعيدا عن اوروبا الشرقيه وبعد
مرور عام على حرب اوكرانيا بدات محركات
الدبلوماسيه تتسارع الصين طرحت خطه لانهاء
الحرب وتركيا قدمت نفسها كوسيط لتنضم
الدوله الى سلسله طويله من الدول برازيل
اندونيسيا اسرائيل وجنوب افريقيا وغيرها
قالت انه على الرغم من تعهد اداره بايدن
المتكرر بدعم اوكرانيا لاقصى مدى زمني الا
ان واشنطن مقيده بحد معين من الاموال
والمعدات التي يمكن للولايات المتحده
ارسالها الى اوكرانيا وفضلا عن الجوانب
التقنيه توجد تيارات ايضا في الحزبين ان
كان الجمهوري او الديمقرا ترفض تحمل
مسؤوليه حرب لا يروح افقا لنهايتها لكن في
هذه الحرب التسويه السريعه التي ربما تفشل
ستكون اسوا من عدم التسويه بحسب الصحيفه
الامريكيه التي قالت ان اي حل دائم يجب ان
يستوفي عده شروط اذا اردنا ان نتذكر او
نذكر هذه الشروط مثلا ان تقبل روسيا
اوكرانيا كمحاور مباشر على ذات الطاوله
وعلى قدم المساواه لا ان تعتبر اوكرانيا
وكيلا عن الدول الغربيه في هذه الحرب
نوهت الى ان روسيا لم تتعامل مع اوكرانيا
كمحاور شرعي خلال جولات متعدده من
الدبلوماسيه تحديدا في عام 2014 و2015
وبدلا من ذلك اعتبرت حينها روسيا الوضعه
في شرق اوكرانيا حربا اهليه داخليه رغم
القتال بين القوات الاوكرانيه والعناصر
المواليه والمدعومه من موسكو هناك شرط اخر
بحسب التقرير هو توصل روسيا واوكرانيا الى
اتفاق بشان التكوين الاقليمي لاوكرانيا
ووحده اراضيها وفي هذا الصدد ذكرت الصحيفه
بمقالات وخطابات للرئيس الروسي منذ عام
2021 حول الوحده التاريخيه بين اوكرانيا
وايضا روسيا
ان الاخفاقات العسكريه الروسيه والدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا ربما يعمقان التزام
بوتين باطاله امد الحرب لكن في ذات الوقت
قد تجد روسيا نفسها في مازق بسبب انفاقها
للموارد في اوكرانيا وقد تتسبب بحسب
الصحيفه باضطرابات سياسيه محليه في مرحله
ما قد تقود الى تهدئه القتال واشارت الى
ان التوصل لحل في اوكرانيا جزء كبير منه
بيد الرئيس الروسي الذي ينبغي ان يراجع
اهدافه الاستراتيجيه بشكل عام
ومحاوله التخلي عن طموحه القاضي باعاده
تشكيل اوروبا وفقا للرؤيه الروسيه